in Dorne were saying 10 years of past
them and humans have let the earth fall
apart Caesar was leading the Apes into a
new era I just thought that in the first
film you so connected to Caesar it's a
very simple story about a very powerful
idea
you became Caesar emotionally the way
you saw him thinking and putting things
together every moment sort of blossoming
Caesar is an outsider
really he said grows up believing he's
one thing and then at a very tender
adolescent ages is then cast off and
thrown into his own kind he's imprisoned
and then he sort of has to find the way
to become you know the master of the
yard
Oh Aaron who's Boston enough Caesar is a
known galvanized all of those Apes
and leads them to freedom capture
people's imaginations and hearts what I
thought was exciting about this idea was
taking that character who was sort of a
revolutionary and watch as he became a
leader you're really following him
through the story
he's a very natural leader Caesar people
respect him he is the Alpha this film
Caesars got to deal with his own flock
he's gonna make choices and compromises
that not everyone respects it's one
thing to be a revolutionary it's another
thing to have a difficult moral dilemma
Cesar has empathy and compassion what he
sees is a world that needs to be shared
who was that a man like you he can't
help but to retain some of the good
things that came with humanity
that's why Caesar than Judas you're
feeling we had a chance more that's
already the God
[Music]
you
[Music]